stories of people who were believers
that became non-believers what caused
that event
um well so there's not as much research
on deconversion there's quite a bit of
research on conversion and i've
summarize some of that deconversion
there's not much uh there's some
research going on now on the nuns the
so-called people that have no religious
affiliation they tick the box for none
under religious in surveys and polls and
and uh you know it it
there's some influence of education for
example more educated people or slightly
less religious but not in a huge way
like you know if you have a graduate
degree you're highly likely to be an
atheist no not not like that at all
and interestingly the the just the last
decade the the percentage of nuns is is
more than doubled it's about about a
quarter of all americans and about a
third of millennials that is people born
after 1981
have no religious affiliation
they're the fastest growing religious
cohort in the country no religious
affiliation
now my atheist friends go aha they're
you know they're going to be atheists
well no not necessarily it's looking
more more like they're turning to more
shall we say secular religions you know
buddhism western buddhism meditation
uh you know the kind of people that go
to deepak troper center and in carl's
bed or they go to esselon institute
where they find a lot of new age
uh spiritual beliefs that are not
religiously related and they don't
believe in a personal god necessarily
but
some kind of higher force or some kind
of
entity or something that exists beyond
us but it usually remains poorly defined
or not defined at all
i mean there's got to be a trend though
because for me i think about i was born
in iran so war happens i see a bunch of
people die
uh i'm uh
seeing stuff that i don't want to really
see i go to church every time my mom and
dad take me to church i get kicked out
of sunday school i keep asking one
question from my sunday school teacher
that she can't answer it's a basic
question
if god so loved the world why is why are
we having so many people die because of
war why did we get bombed 165 times the
other day if he loves
us so much why did this happen well you
know finally she calls my mom and dad
and saying your son can no longer mean
bible study because for four straight
weeks she couldn't answer one basic
question right so i go to germany i see
some behavior by a
armenian pastor that completely turned
me off from uh
a certain way he was behaving around my
family didn't like that and i called him
out on it and i was a 10 11 year old kid
he didn't like that too much but you
know it's uh i'm my father's son and i'm
a protector and then we come to the
states go to the army i'm still an
atheist 25 years of my life i'm an a i'm
i'm an atheist right
so then eventually i study everything
scientology do whatever i can get my
hands on because i'm curious lds
mormonism joseph smith jehovah you read
the books case for christ case for
church all these things
but i also saw a trend
why believers became non-believers
typically
there was a letdown by either a
religious leader who set the example
and he did something you know whether
it's a behavior
normally it's uh it's a what do you call
it a girl a woman you know kid drugs he
wants to leave the life so you're
disappointed oh my god i cannot believe
this pastor did this there's no way in
the world i'm going to be catholic
christian so you'll leave the life right
typically it's a disappointment by a
father figure somebody in the family but
there's also a heartbreak when they pray
because they lose a loved one and that
absolutely crushes them right where they
sit and say look i pray for this you
didn't answer my question why am i going
to believe in god would you mind sharing
the story of maureen with the audience
for them to kind of uh
and tell me if that had any effects for
you because i can tell you for me
that was my biggest disappointment
because i lost a loved one what kind of
an effect did i have on your faith
yeah yeah sure i'll share that story
momentarily i think you've tapped into
though a huge issue that is that what's
called the odyssey or the problem of
evil why bad things happen to good
people now theists will argue well the
examples you just gave uh of war that's
human cause that we attribute to agency
free will humans have free will god gave
us free will and we made bad choices so
too bad
that and that goes back to the fall in
the garden uh when you know adam and eve
and that whole story that we are by
nature sinful and that's part of the
sinful nature
uh that uh theists
are willing to agree we have and and so
things like war homicide genocide rape
torture so on you know those are human
caused okay
so that's one thing but and that i agree
with you that is problematic from a you
know a theistic point of view but they
do have a response to that but they
don't have a good response to in my
opinion
is natural evil that is tsunamis
earthquakes childhood leukemia i mean
just take that one or just take the
thousands of children that die every
year from starvation
i mean we know what they need
and uh you know the bill gates of the
world can only do so much why can't god
do what bill gates does i mean why can't
he help it you know this is these are
like a one-year-old what kind of
volition an agency does a one-year-old
have who gets you know leukemia and dies
a horrible miserable life suffering and
then the parents suffer for the rest of
their lives losing their children
and uh atheists in my opinion do not
have a good answer to that so i think
you've made a correct
deduction there and in the case you
asked about maureen was my girlfriend in
uh at pepperdine and and for several
years after in graduate school and so on
and she got in a bad car accident and
broke her back and uh this was the
sweetest wonderful smartest nicest woman
i knew and i just could not believe that
this happened and i was kind of in the
transition from leaving to leaving my
religion and becoming a non-believer but
for a moment i thought you know what i'm
just gonna pray for her because you know
maybe there is a god what do i know and
uh you know if anybody deserves to be
healed it's her and i you know you talk
to a million christians and you'll get a
million stories of you know people that
are miraculously healed you know they
prayed to god and god you know reached
into the
world and and performed a miracle why
not why not her well of course nothing
happened and she's still paralyzed to
this day and so it's like why that now i
wasn't putting god to some you know test
it wasn't a public thing i didn't write
about it for decades afterwards
and um but i just thought you know what
that's a good
i know one last nail in the coffin so to
speak of the death of god for me
was you know i think it's more likely
that just bad things happen that they do
just you know this bumper sticker says
[ __ ] happens it's the second law of
thermodynamics it's entropy you know
there's just more ways for things to go
wrong than things to go right just think
of a sand castle at the beach you know
how many how many ways are there to push
grains of sand together into something
that looks like a castle not many
compared to the near infinite ways the
grains could be molded into just uh
featureless lumps
and that's a metaphor for the human body
just way more things to go wrong than
right
and and so people get cancer just
randomly it's just there's no meaning
behind it at all and and if there is a
god and he's all good and all powerful
then it's an indictment
that he's not all good if he doesn't do
anything about it so that's my take so
if you like this sort of short clip from
an interview i did click over here to
watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]
you